the average Haitian household spends
about $10 per month on kerosene and
candles to light their home with
electricity it only cost them about $2
per month
I started coming to Les Anglais in 2008
and from the very beginning there was
this idea that eventually we would be
able to build a grid here in order to
provide higher level energy services not
using gas joy may havoc a levy which I
do it's you comma six zeros delayed
the cell phone company has an antenna
here which is powered by a diesel
generator and we're transmitting excess
capacity into our micro grid to serve
our customers we're trying to help
people consume the electricity that they
want to consume by selling them
electricity credits on a prepaid basis
rather than sending them a bill at the
end of every month and then not
necessarily having the money to pay for
that
we have a couple of employees who make
rounds each day checking the amount of
energy consumed on each meter and we
calculate how much energy is left on
each customer's account and if that
balance goes to 0 then we notify the
customer if they then want to put more
money on their account they just go to
the local business that we have a
partnership with and they give them
their cash we're demonstrating the power
of efficiency to deliver higher quality
and a larger quantity of energy services
here we're going immediately to LED
light bulbs
Viswa power Telmo be loose Waconia
Kousaka méxico visa a vociferous ugly
Alain Ducasse yok mu is people the
ecology that you
yep guy who shall he deliver go so he
will shop like that to new policy when
he would wish on them that actually
we're really looking to reproduce this
model in other parts of Haiti that would
also benefit from microgrids
like we won't put away see development
total